[Música]
muito boa tarde a todos
espero dela 12 minutos espero que ele
compreende 18 em prática não financiar
muito antes de mais queria agradecer a
os organizadores o facto de terem
combinado
levamos não estava entendendo os degraus
da nanotecnologia que nós fazemos mais
precisamente ontem americana faculdade
de ciências e tecnologia da usaa nova de
lisboa em zurique também cumprimentar os
jogadores falaram anos e meio e que tudo
aquilo que foi visto se aplicar todas
essa rotina da minha terra' de
investigação científica considera que
todas essas funções todos estes cuidados
todas estas escadas são anjos é tudo por
1 0
a nossa vida ao nosso trabalho aos
nossos afetos ao todo foram feridas com
porteira dos meus resultados em inglês
mas são poucas palavras planta mais
gráficos e imagens
espero que compreendam e flavia pennetta
que nós podemos cobrar isso do outro
lado nós temos uma temos dante equipe
que temos trabalho nós temos temos um
tanto uma estratégia no laboratório e
essa estratégia de novo disse o soldado
dos materiais de trabalho reage não tem
com gesso time pretende aplicar na área
da eletrônica
nós vamos trabalhar como ele acha que
pode transformar as filiais em
dispositivo
em circuitos integrados nós temos essas
duas grandes estratégias no laboratório
é primavera em pisar materiais amigos da
natureza ou seja é muita tinta na
natureza fizeram trabalhos como é que
haja muito cachorro ou materiais tóxicos
e como temos que expulsar os materiais
que eles utilizaram tecnologias é como
fazer um povo vocês para fazer nenhum
volta à inter varinha och sul café podem
ter outros menos mas depois tem que ter
uma tecnologia ou é um microondas ou é
um forno ou é que for também usava de
tecnologia para transformar em danos
materiais
e nós também temos nossas tecnologias
que utilizamos tentar utilizar
tecnologias que sejam amigas do ambiente
e não requer muita energia o começo não
sejam limpas não abrir a minha ou seja
na altura - a estratégia que nós temos
com deus muita área da eletrônica pelas
melhorias que nós conduzimos que nós
fabricamos entrada da eletrônica é hoje
em dia existem alguns problemas de um
mundo que pode tocar lá inteiro isto vai
ter de provar junto ao nacional não toda
forma o gás da europa estou inteiro no
baixo
existem alguns problemas que nós hoje em
dia temos na área da eletrônica eixos
hoje em dia temos comissões tem 79 anos
estamos rodeados de muita tecnologia
a última longa agenda apenas técnico
acho que só no telemóvel temos temos
podemos fazer tudo coisas que a geórgia
não não é há tanto tempo como isso não
podemos fazer só conquistei que nós
estamos a fazer hoje me portanto parte
desta tecnologia destes equipamentos
eletrônicos com novos arranjos hoje e há
uns anos eu sou muito difíceis ser
reciclados
então nós estamos a produzir aquilo que
chama o até porque acho o acesso lixo
eletrônico e esse trecho portanto é
exatamente o lixo e deixe destes
equipamentos eletrônicos estão
assentadas desta forma a minha meninada
mas como é evidente não é isso nós um
dia aconteça isso é um outro tipo de
seleção em andamento em vez de materiais
têxteis que o que acontece com tanta
imagina você já o português de
telemóveis verdade bom provincial da
wired acho que nós hoje em dia nós
estávamos a resolver este problema
nós estamos implementando no planetário
os problemas para outras partes do mundo
novo na minha mente para o hemisfério
fogo da instituição as rotas
internacionais o disco bicho eletrônico
basicamente a américa do norte ea europa
estão a de localizar os testados juntas
as premiações olha que talvez da áfrica
china ele é engenheiro que isso não é
descartável se novo gene e continuamos
usar terminal de unidades como sérgio
ocorre o volume no entanto a taxa que os
termos usados hoje em dia nós da equipe
no mundo produz anos não temos de
esfriar
feliz não só o infinito tentar ter muito
muito é muito cuidado com os materiais
que nós precisamos de geninho agora se
gosta quer muito estar exatamente porque
sou materiais khan à escola há algum
cidade começou a ser realizado no dia
que eu sempre digo o outro problema
muito grave que existe penso vocês
também já devem ter ouvido falar e é
parte da punição custo ártico sociais ou
os micro acho que ainda temos alguma
vantagem
assim o público sempre foram analisados
e o sal tem nos 50m eu acho que eu seja
nos genes trazer com ele quando fizemos
a outros jogos - um país possam ser
comigo enquanto as redes
o pronome eu achei que esse dia não faz
muito mal
o problema é que me que eu acho que
funciona isto acha que funciona com os
coxas e no interior dos machos sociais
vão absorver metais pesados e chutar
cruzado centro né
a alimentária cada um continue terá de
pagar ou seja é tanta que algumas
imagens de alguns rios vai ter como
podem ajudar de querer perpetuar texto
assegura mais de 100 habitantes só
materiais estes cannon não saldada chão
sagrado
estamos a caminho de uma cola pronto e
soul/r&b também é mais um mero a imagem
em preto
daqui por 10 nós somos tratados temas
oceanos continuar a fazer esta punição
daqui por diante os filhos mais plástico
nos oceanos do que tais
quem falou que ia buscar uma vez que as
pescas
eu acho que isso pessoas olha só de si
faz as correntes oceânicas portanto são
as horas onde estes plásticos futebol no
brasil o segmento está em uma série de
problemas que nós habitantes foram 14
como está
todos esses problemas têm que ser já não
podem ser evitados porque origem mas tem
que ser minimizados
espero só que eliminem são despejados
todos usados cerca de 18 milhões de
toneladas estão associados
isto é o que acontece hoje é bom
face às folhas todos de pacto de
sustentabilidade dão que já não quiser é
só uma teoria alternativa e trabalhando
nós cola eletrônica de trabalhar porque
o texto que eventualmente devem ter uma
escolar foi um transístor de papel em
poder utilizar materiais alternativos de
origem renovável como jajá celulose para
fazer eletrônico em obesos cientistas
eu penso que este vil descarregar ele
precisa funcionar talvez até um pouco
com o solo está não sei se vocês
recomendam destas imagens só são
conhecidas
tanto eu a cota e por meus novos
cientistas também sou um cara bem
inspirados pela ficção científica
portanto existem não só no caso do bric
potter mas também no caso do sistema
espanhol dá ao mesmo são quadros não
querem mais para trás e foram os
goleiros
sou governo tanto junho ver na altura
quando escreveu a viagem à lua
a viagem costuma dar início à
apresentação do sobrinho 60
nada de cirurgia existia no próprio
acabou por conhecer e ver essa
tecnologia em funcionamento no passado
usaram duas décadas diz tudo é possível
por vezes a ficção científica pracinha e
também tendo problemas com enchentes
comecem a pensar nessas coisas em anadia
ter funções e tudo podem tornar esta
ficção em revelar
então nosso empenho baseados nas
histórias no arre potter e naquelas
imagens com vídeos regionais é de 60
lembrar pôde utilizar um material muito
ver aquele estádio de futebol que a sua
loja exatamente para fazer eletrônica
tentava cruzar a material de origem
renovável é muito e muito barato e
letrada
contudo hoje em dia um sábado fora então
podemos pensar assim mas hoje nós temos
mais uma vez tcheco diários nos impedem
os atletas técnicos e bocas do jornal
hoje em dia não autorizar os jornalistas
legítimo telemóvel um ipad
tá uma tendência é utilizar em
substituir o o os jornais tudo que é da
penha os próprios livros por
equipamentos eletrônicos
olha há também uma tendência e as
próprias anos diz que fazem produzem
telas estão preocupadas porque o livro
de papel para jornais pelas linhas a
esses documentos está a diminuir
cantar que usava papel outras aplicações
com problema como por exemplo jamais
papel de embalagem e substituir partida
que os plásticos são deitados sociais
estamos tetrapak é certo e também há uma
tendência ao na movimentação grande
parte das indústrias relacionadas com
tabela pontual porque nós pensávamos que
tem pesado de outros assuntos também até
no primeiro existe até nós fizemos foi
quando uma folha como foi na maldade
photoshop
sua voz é um material é o biopolímero
mais abundante na terra é o material no
papel material flexível em novos padres
insta algumas aplicações é muito
importante
jovens nós trabalhamos muito em
circuitos integrados cheia também querem
colar em vidro ou mesmo é eu acho que se
iniciou em creches disse patten doar o
material tem um custo barato em um
material que também é muito leve e hoje
em dia ser modificadas tanto peso é
produção do papel está perfeitamente
estão sendo 9
temos de ter orgulho de tê-la atuária
que o papel do luverdense uma qualidade
em termos de tecnologia para fabricar o
papel que ela existe nós não precisamos
de atraso
temos de inventar nada tudo verdade
tenho duas propriedades elétricas sabiá
- qual é o material os materiais
condutores ofertava que ele sabe qual é
o melhor que existe tem buscado acelerar
qualquer condutor sabino a tapas com o
papel que o papel não conduzir deve ser
a do papel tem boas propriedades ano
antes do voto em papel é o meio oficial
que está em nós consigamos fazer um
dispositivo é muito fácil transportar
em 5 podemos fazer estas eletrônicas
para fazer uma série de coisas no rio
podemos reciclar outra vez de fazer mais
bastante campeão em fazer mais letrada
teve 15 complementos completamente chá
bom mas também alto nível de perto ainda
o seu papel tem alguns problemas por
outro lado nós temos que ter outras
alternativas como eu tava dizer que se
nós olharmos por exemplo para é que o
que acontece à sua origem vegetal que é
dados
eu tenho que mostrar uma média de quatro
a cinco anos para que eu tenha otto
alencar deixa a desejar em 11 de maio
que justifica com o seu abadá para
produzir papel para ser ele a sua voz da
madeira e agora esse tempo todo enquanto
existe uma alternativa que não seja só
seis reconhecem que também é percorrido
em nada portanto vi nada tem umas
baterias que não são patogénicas também
gosta dos apenados também as bactérias
em nosso dna essa estratégia também a
bactérias boas e essas matérias que
estão no vinagre produzindo também isso
nós já não está em tempo de mudança tudo
é suor do mundo mora reta 23 deles
destaca o exemplo das suas bactérias
chegou primeiro no evento porque está
tocada existe no vinagre chamas a ser
tomada tanto vinagre f27 dela nascer
tobata e estas baterias têm a capacidade
no seu modo como mecanismo de defesa de
todos em uma estrutura tridimensional de
fibras de celulose mexeu nó fibras
chorarem desta escola é muito pequenina
que elas funcionam como mas nós
produtoras ou produzindo em função do
maior banco estatal fibras vão ser dez
com fibras de celulose eu posso prometer
que o papel de origem bacteriana
isso é que eu eu eu é o aspecto a peça
até aos tal do mato rico é de são ótimos
e psicológico produzida pelas baterias
do governador estão aí para mostrar que
existem alternativas portal é celulose
bacana do giestal temos uma explosão
hoje bacteriana e soldados e equipes das
duas imagens têm uma imagem é obtida por
microscopia eletrônica do evento do de
uma folha tabela
se vocês olharem forem ver observar um
microscópio eletrônico nome dos quatro
atacantes que mais fala muito pequenas e
micro ondas na bateria só nosso cabelo
tem cerca de 60 micro ondas de pessoas
têm que usar as suas fibras de celulose
que existem uma folha normal tabela
destaque são as fibras suor produzidas
pela bactéria
hoje o pt é muito similar à de uma rede
tridimensional defender as questões
postas de uma forma aleatória
só que quem escala é completamente prevê
que temos 100 mícrons aqui temos sete
menores
o nome é da - nó do meta agora pra ter
uma noção das escolas na área das
nanotecnologias se dividir uma bola de
tênis da escola nela mineiro pôde entrar
na história dessa para nós todas as
propriedades fiquem sobre as
propriedades óticas duas quebras
nesse nosso papel mas só nossa
no dia de hoje bater dentro daquela
conquista da linha branca porque as
fibras são grandes porque elas absorvem
a organização
nela desliga no caso das 9 horas por
dias pela bactéria ela chora tão
pequeninos que não vai rever a ação dos
visíveis com as fibras de papel fica
semitransparentes quando nós trabalhando
com ele a troca de papel como fizemos
alguns jogos dá alguns exemplos no
trabalho que temos feito um centro de
investigação de materiais na área de tv
dawn respectivos filhos o chapéu como
diz o primeiro existe o papel já foi
afetado 60 vai fazer dez anos agora em
2008 ea tendência homogênea e nossos
objetivos da tabela por equipamentos
eletrônicos mas nós que estamos perdendo
em sentido contrário e talvez mesmo o
nosso sucesso nós não precisamos fazer
só repetir aquilo que os outros façam
uma função de fazer diferente eo efeito
foi exatamente isso usar continuar a
usar a celulose é usada hoje machos leis
para comprar menos letrados gosta já é
celulose em um material que pode ser
usado em eletrônica e do início das
aulas o e da esquerda para investir nos
rita
passamos aquele time de geninho ou seja
continuamos usar são loffi para
aplicação e letrada sistema de ensino
ser um exemplo vou dar aqui uma aula
transistor falar dessas coisas mas
fazendo um transístor de papel é muito
simples é praticamente um ovo de colombo
no fundo é mais do que fazer uma
fotocópia frente e verso acho que o
papel numa das faces com um belo
material condutor não outra faz um belo
material semicondutor e tem muita gente
estamos a assistir ao especial prefeita
não interessa
nós temos outras histórias
foi isso que nós fizemos já em 2008
também mais recentemente fizemos este
mesmo os transistores o presidente bateu
és o nosso papel que quiserem produzir
pelas bactérias nós mesmos planos de
maquiné no pé tendo como as fibras se
unam métricas é eu é mais rápida não
temos aqui um exemplo novamente o
trânsito e podem vetar disse ter quase
um filho vem do trânsito é basicamente
extrativistas funcionam como como suíte
1 o nó focados lugar está ligado
neste caso a holanda já pensa em deixar
de ter uma nova em relacionar trânsito
susan destas bactérias sheik só uma
imagem é também político eletrônica
primeira secção dos anjos ao acordo que
temos vários elementos que compõem este
trânsito
este é um aspecto que esse camarada
destes materiais que nós jogamos e
fantasias são todos meninos que não
alteramos as folhas de papel tanto tempo
apela para escrever no papel ela teve
que escrever sobre circuitos integrados
sobre isto
temos também o condutor quer dizer que
em uma folha de papel como levo que
sendo podemos transformar o papel queijo
é como o papel condutor é quem mais de
200 central é de fazer um transístor
sozinho fazendo pela contadora podemos
integrar o subtenente eletrônico em
terceiro na tabela
vários protótipos que nós fizemos em
conjunto com a luxa deu o exemplo de
circuitos integrados usando a tabela
não vou entrar e dar pra valer a pena
propriamente dita não vai fazer mas
precisamos ter a energia então usados o
t par que já tem impacto do alumínio
funciona como contar que lembre o que
fizemos é luxo a shit pacto e chamamos
pessoal porque nós quisemos ter esta
eletrônica também papel não vou ligar
pois um cabo elétrico uma tomada do
estudo a corrente elétrica independente
disso tem desenvolver sistemas que sejam
autossuficientes
o conselho os quais o oco bateria
seguindo o exemplo do marcelo lutar o
papel produzido pelas parteiras e já
agora eu estou falando do papel e hoje
em dia o material pode deixar de meter
muito falar é que já ouvi falar no
grafeno foi dada no ar há alguns que
está hoje muito na moda aliás foi o
prémio nobel da física por exemplo fazer
grandes desafios shopping da cidade de
materiais que nós temos são de origem
renovável
desta forma eletrônica e também
trabalhamos muito na área dos vinhos
sensores o teste do dinheiro norte tem
taxa de simples gravidez até chega com
costa falava sobre isso jato alugado
existem várias tecnologias para nós
produzimos aqui os testes no menor que
as empresas não possam não sabem que
terminar o show vai pessoal sabe que eu
usei josé ruído mas hoje ele a tendência
é nós temos um chip e uma mudinha de sá
que temos toda a informação que vai ter
nos laboratórios de análises clínicas e
oficinas o amor um chip e nós
contratamos um papel que chegaram a
circular a bola vai pintar no clube
assim tabela também posso criar novos
canais e também teste diagnóstico é
ainda pior
isso é muito fácil tanto papel material
que gosta de água é hidrofílico alma
cheia de pessoas à base de cera da xerox
se nós podemos criar lama impressora
normal
gente vamos ter de trabalhar com seu
equipamento é uma coisa que me dá
queremos imprimir rs é definir a cena no
papel de criar da área senão fóbica ser
assim o mercado de fome
o intelligent sensor chapéu é que o
xexéu
trago costa nós desenvolvemos em papel é
que isso carregar um vídeo temos aqui um
exemplo que estão na onda da cintel nós
temos aqui em duas zonas conselho é
transparente ou seja já que os canais
que estão indo bem no papel teve que em
13 indicadores que têm uma menina
para nuno costa temos aqui uma solução
com açúcar em um líquido à chegada a
estas zonas portal é a uma reação
química uma mudança de pegar e temos
aqui os indicadores com drogba quarta
temos sensores como elemento que porta o
caso da costa e quem concorre em outras
coisas
tentamos tirar sua estreita aquilo que
nós pretendemos fazer nada no papel não
queremos só fazer transições não
queremos só fazer o teste e norte paulo
costa
queremos fazer memória que fazer
baterias e partes que já foram feitas
nos treinadores sensor seu histórico
como eu disse entender a tudo isto em
sistemas minha beleza
as grandes aplicações é na área de saúde
por lógica da mês de março devemos mais
tempo linda das melhores que é viver
mais tempo com o poder da vida e cada
vez mais temos uma cena de sensores e
podemos fazer esta
por exemplo uma transição em casa seja a
água pra comida e pra que está aqui quem
tem a minha vida as coisas penso vocês
já ouviram o que agora já assistem à
internet de todas as coisas sempre muito
muito muito próximo
tudo vai publicar conteúdo e para isso
nós precisamos ter em troca de muito
baixo custo
daí querer que não estranha que sejam
tem sido feito mesmo terminar nós temos
aqui ô ô ô emma e isto também se aplica
a você estava seguindo a atual a nossa
vida futura
isto é um trabalho de quinta todas essas
coisas contou com um trabalho singular e
nós estamos muito deste governo é ficar
costuma cantar mês
se quiser chegar rápido você vai sozinho
se quiser chegar nós vai acompanhar
precisa perder o frio chegar mais longe
pra isso queremos ir acompanhados por
texto ou venda em o lema eu posso também
devem partilhar e deve realizar trabalho
em equipe é fundamental
alguns agradecimentos portanto nós temos
tido é só ter um instinto beijar acho
que podemos fazer pouco o projeto de lei
1209 fundos nacionais é que permitem
trabalhar nas centenas de projetos ou
financeiro financial times ou o pai é
piloto - de água do mar em alta marcando
castigados
já agora gostaria de ver com os negócios
só espero que você se algum de vocês nem
todas as classes e tecnologia gastou
desde já convidados a visitar resultados
nós sobre idosos foi preso quando estava
a promover entre outra coisa nunca na
vossa vida tenham complexo né suprimidas
nem filha e sempre importante
nós também queremos justiça
eu tive quando começamos dessa concepção
nós temos vários pretendentes com a
samsung a pele sul e os coreanos venda
em portugal eu disse é nossa
responsabilidade e os dois colegas
disseram conviver com fechos mas acho
que tá na moda e 10 na rua do espelho já
a final b trânsito que só para nos dizer
que acredita em cento e conselho se os
outros conseguem não sei se conseguirei
mais proteínas que consegue estão já fez
e faz um ponto por baixa
portanto quando temos paixão pelo que
fazemos nós quem chegar com grande lá e
impossíveis
dóia
[Música]